GEOFF SCHULLER: One of the
most challenging things
about designing an
application for Android Auto
is providing access
to the content
and the features apps provide
in a simple and usable way,
so drivers can focus
on what they really
need to be doing in the car.
And that's driving it.
I'm Geoff, and I'm a designer
on the Android Auto team.
We understand these challenges.
And we've created some very
important design patterns
and guidelines that you can
use when you create or adapt
your app to work
on Android Auto.
Now it might seem obvious,
but it really must be said.
The most important
thing a driver
needs to do while they're in the
car is drive, with their eyes
on the road and their
hands on the wheel.
When designing for drivers,
it's important to remember
that driving is
their primary task,
and using Android Auto
is a secondary task.
When we designed
Android Auto, our goal
was to simplify all interactions
and minimize distraction.
Every part of the interface
has been carefully considered.
And sometimes, this
requires tough decisions
to be made to ensure simplicity.
As an example, we've set
a goal that all tasks
should be completed in six
button presses or less.
This is a very
important guideline.
And it's enforced
via our platform
when drivers interact
with items in the drawer.
If you want to provide a
great Android Auto experience
for your users, keep watching.
We're about to tell
you how we accomplish
this in the applications
we designed for drivers.
Now as an interaction designer
on the Android Auto team,
I'm responsible for taking
apps like Google Play
Music and the Dialer and making
them ready for use in the car.
And that could be
pretty challenging
when you consider
how many contacts
and how much music we
all have in our phones.
Typical Android users have
anywhere between 100 and 1,000
contacts on their phones, and
up to 18 days' worth of music.
Even more if you use a
music subscription service.
How can you possibly
browse through the list
of who you want to
call or what you
want to listen to when you've
got that much content to choose
from?
The truth is, you can't.
While designing Google
Play Music and Dialer
for Android Auto,
we had to find a way
to provide access
to the features
and content in those apps while
staying within the six step
limit.
It was challenging.
And it is possible.
Here's how we did it.
First, we took a good hard
look at each application
and thought about the
things that drivers really
needed while driving.
In Dialer, we focused
on speed dial,
because it already
provides a nice way
to call the people that
we talk to the most.
We kept the list
short, so drivers
wouldn't have to scroll through
very many items while driving.
Four pages is the most.
No more than that.
And we used voice commands
for complex interactions
like calling a contact
that doesn't already
appear in speed dial.
It's much easier to tap
the mic and say something
like, call Benmont Tench,
rather than scrolling
through a long list of
contacts to find him.
We put other functionality
like voicemail,
dial a number, missed calls,
and call history in the drawer,
so drivers could access
those if they needed them.
And again, we kept
the list short,
only displaying four pages of
missed calls and call history.
You really don't need more
than that while you're driving.
All of these design
choices helped
us to keep interactions
simple and achievable
and six taps or less.
Now let's look at
Google Play Music.
When you look at
the mobile version,
you'll see many things that
are useful for drivers--
things like listen now,
playlists, and radio.
Those are great, and we included
them in the Android Auto
version, but shortened the list
length to four pages' worth
of items, so the driver could
find what they want and select
it in six taps or less.
Now let's look at
Explorer and My Library.
These have many categories
and long lists of content.
It really isn't possible
to browse all the content
in these categories
effectively while driving.
So what did we do?
Well, we chose to
use voice commands
to say things like,
play Tom Petty,
or play "Full Moon Fever," or
play "Runnin' Down a Dream."
This is a much faster
way to play something
by an artist, or an
album, or a song.
Let's listen to something else.
Play "Stop Stalling."
COMPUTER VOICE: Playing
"Stop Stalling."
[MUSIC - DERBY, "STOP STALLING"]
GEOFF SCHULLER: If
you want drivers
to be able to use voice
commands in your app,
implement the play this
item on this app command.
There's a whole DevByte
on that right here.
We realized that
designing for drivers
requires you to consider things
that you wouldn't normally
have to do when you're
designing a mobile app.
And we know this
can be a challenge.
But we're here to help.
We published some very helpful
design patterns and guidelines,
which you can use to adapt
your app for Android Auto.
You can check them
out right here.
And I'll cover a few of the
important ones right now.
First, take a good
hard look at your app
and think about the
things drivers really
need while driving.
Next, think about
the voice commands
you can add to make it
easier for drivers to do
the things they need to do.
Last, and most importantly,
keep your lists short
and the depth of your
content hierarchy shallow,
and understand that
Android Auto's drawer
code keeps track of the taps.
Every tap the driver
uses to open the drawer
and scroll forward through
the content is counted.
And the driver can only
tap five more times
once the drawer's open to find
and tap the item they want.
If your content
hierarchy is too deep,
the driver will run out of
taps and will be stopped
from browsing any further.
You can avoid this by
doing the following.
Only include the content and
categories the driver really
needs while driving.
Next, limit the first level of
the drawer to one or two pages.
And last, know that any
forward scrolls or taps
the driver performs
in level one reduces
the amount of content
and categories
they can see on
subsequent levels.
If you follow the two
and three level drawer
patterns that we provided
at the developer website
and keep your nav
hierarchy shallow,
drivers will be able to
access the content they
care about the
most while driving
and will have a great
experience while using
your app in Android.
Thanks for watching, and
we wish you all the best
as you design your app for
the Android Auto driver.
[MUSIC PLAYING]